CYCLE.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S ELECTION NIGHT IN
AMERICA.
TOMORROW, ELECTION DAY.
JOINING US, OUR POLLSTERS, MATT
TOWERY AND ROBERT CAHALY.
TRAFALGAR.
THEY HAVE BEEN POLLING EVERY
RACE.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
THIS IS YOUR FINAL OPPORTUNITY.
WE'RE GOING TO BE GO THROUGH
ESPECIALLY THE SENATE RACES.
A LOT OF THESE GUBERNATORIAL
RACES.
LET'S START IN THE GREAT STATE
OF GEORGIA.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE HERSCHEL
WALKNER THE LEAD.
ROBERT CAHALY, WHO WILL HAPPEN
TOMORROW?
>> I THINK HERSCHEL WILL COME IN
FIRST AND I THINK HE'S GOING TO
GET IT BARELY AND AVOID A
RUN-OFF.
>> Sean: YOU THINK IT'S A
RUN-OFF DECEMBER 6.
>> I THINK HE AVOIDS IT.
>> Sean: YOU THINK HE AVOIDS IT.
BARELY.
THAT WOULD BE A BIG NIGHT FOR
REPUBLICANS IF THAT HAPPENS.
MATT TOWERY, DO YOU AGREE?
>> WELL, I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I'M
INCREASINGLY CONVINCED THAT
ROBERT IS THE BEST POLLSTER ON
THIS.
I THINK HERSCHEL WALKER WILL
MAKE IT ACROSS THE 50% PLUS ONE.
PARTLY BECAUSE AFRICAN AMERICAN
MEN WILL VOTE FOR WALKER AT AN
EVEN HIGHER LEVEL THAN THEY HAVE
TOLD US IN THE POLLS.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T DENY BRIAN
KEMP HAS RUN A GREAT CAMPAIGN
FOR GOVERNOR.
>> OH, YEAH.
HE'S LIFTING ALL VOTES IN
GEORGIA.
HE'S GOING TO ABSOLUTELY -- HE
WILL HAVE A BIG NIGHT.
LET'S PUTS IT THAT WAY OVER
STACEY ABRAMS.
YES, BRIAN KEMP WILL ADD TO
HERSCHEL WALKER'S LIKELIHOOD OF
MAKING IT WITHOUT A RUN OFF.
>> Sean: LET'S GO TO NORTH
CAROLINA AND TED BUDD.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THAT RACE?
>> BUDD.
THAT IS EASY.
>> Sean: ROBERT, AGREEMENT?
>> YES.
BUDD COMFORTABLY.
>> LET'S GO TO NEW HAMPSHIRE.
A POLL CAME OUT TODAY HAD
GENERAL BOLDUC UP BY ONE.
YOU HAVE A
GOVERN
LEADING ANYWHERE FROM 12 TO 18
POINTS IN SOME POLLS.
IS THAT GOING TO HELP GENERAL
BOLDUC WHO ALSO HAD A GOOD
DEBATE AGAINST MAGGIE HASSAN.
WHERE IS THAT STATE GOING, MATT
TOWERY?
>> WELL, IT'S VERY CLOSE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT EARLY
VOTING.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF NOISE
BEFORE THE ACTUAL ELECTION.
HE'S BEEN RISING THE ENTIRE
TIME.
THE BRITISH BETTING HOUSES SAY
HE'S NOT GOING TO WIN.
I SAY HE HAS A CHANCE OF
WINNING.
IT WILL BE CLOSE.
ROBERT THINKS I THINK THAT IT'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE CLOSER.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
ROBERT?
>> YEAH, I THINK JUST EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SAID.
HE HAD A GREAT DEBATE.
HE HAS GOVERNOR SUNUNU BEHIND
HIM.
THAT'S A BIG MOVE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS DONE A BUNCH OF
TOWN HALLS AND MAGGIE HASSAN SAT
IN THE BASEMENT.
IN THE END, HE PULLS IT OUT.
I SAID BOLDUC WINS IT.
>> Sean: LOOK AT GENERAL BOLDUC.
HE'S NOT A POLISHED POLITICIAN.
HE'S BEN A GENERAL.
HE DID TEN TOURS OF DUTY, TWO
PURPLE HARTS, FIVE BRONZE STARS.
HE'S IN IT TO SERVE.
HE WOULD BE A GREAT CHOICE.
I HOPE HE PULLS THIS OUT.
LET'S GO TO THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE PAID A LOT OF ATTENTION TO
THIS RACE.
YOU HAVE I THINK IN JOHN
FETTERMAN, THE MOST EXTREME
CANDIDATE EVER TO RUN FOR THE
U.S. SENATE.
IT'S STILL RELATIVELY CLOSE.
YOUR TAKE, ROBERT.
>> I THINK IN THE END, OZ IS
GOING TO GET THE MOST VOTES.
I THINK MASTIAN KNOW OUTPERFORMS
ALL OF HIS POLLING AND MAKES
THAT A LITTLE MORE COMPETITIVE
THAN ANYBODY GIVES HIM CREDIT
FOR.
AFTER PENNSYLVANIA DRAGS IT OUT
IS ANYBODY'S GUESS.
>> Sean: HE GETS THE MOST VOTES.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE CODE WORDS.
MATT?
>> I ALLUDED A MOMENT AGO TO THE
BRITISH ODDS MAKERS THAT TEND TO
BE THE VERY BEST AT FIGURING OUT
AMERICAN POLITICS.
GO FIGURE.
THAT I HAVE MOVED THIS RACE TO
FAVOR OZ WINNING.
SO HAS LARRY SABATO.
OUR POLL IN PHILADELPHIA HAD OZ
UP BY SEVERAL POINTS.
I THINK OZ WILL WIN THE RACE.
IT'S GOING TO BE TIGHT AND I
AGREE WITH ROBERT.
HE WILL GET THE MOST VOTES.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Sean: I WILL ARGUE THAT JOHN
FETTERMAN, IF YOU'RE IN
PENNSYLVANIA, YOU CAN'T LET THAT
HANS.
LET'S LOOK AT J.D. VANCE AND RON
JOHNSON.
ANY ISSUES THERE FOR EITHER OF
YOU?
>> NONE.
THEY BOTH
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO THE STATE OF
ARIZONA.
BLAKE MASTERS.
ROBERT, YOU HAD HIM UP BY THREE
TODAY.
>> ACTUALLY, OUR BRAND NEW POLL
HAS HIM UP BY ONE.
THAT'S THE FIRST POLL THAT WE'VE
PUT OUT WITH MASTERS WINNING.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN HAPPEN IS WHAT
WE EXPECTED.
ONCE THIS LIBERTARIAN GOT OUT,
LOOKS LIKE MASTERS IS --
>> Sean: WE'RE GOING TO DIP BACK
IN T